Ciao ragazzi Bentornati una puntata di
cucina buttata Perdonate la mancanza di
entusiasmo ma oggi stiamo per fare una
cosa orribile due cose orribili la prima
una ricetta ed è consigliato on-line che
prevede il riso più l'unione di un
panettone una roba una scena che fa
cagare poi aggiungi il riso che è una
cosa che mi fa rosicare il riso cioè io
penso che poi cosa mi faccio rosicare
come che ti dice ti ho fatto il risotto
e in tutto questo aggiungeremo
Alessandro Cellini per cui facciamo
venire con estremo piacere il mio ospite
della puntata di oggi
Grazie grazie mille Guglielmo per la
veramente per la presentazione Veramente
Anch'io provo a chiedere a Gianmarco
Enrico va ragazzi Guglielmo fuori perché
cucinarsi con lui così è più o meno
andata ma non è affatto vero che retta
perché abbiamo scoperto una cosa
pazzesca
Grazie per cui Preparatevi a scrivere i
vostri peggiori commenti qua sotto la
prima volta che cucina in vita mia e la
prima volta in cucina buttata
domande di diritto Quanti anni hai
Quanti me ne dai 19
tu in 19 anni non hai mai cucinato nel
senso mai che sei rimasta sola a casa ti
fa 16 anni che ti sei fatto un piatto di
pasta ma il peggio l'ho mai fatto Ecco
il problema è che ci credo la
lavastoviglie l'hai fatta No una
lavatrice non ho pulito
portato a fare il
bravo Mamma mia
mi scaldo il latte la mattina
sì sì sì vabbè cioè
questo da solo
sicuramente per cucinare un risotto
correndo dall'inizio perché lo devo
cucinare Io guardo e lui sentirai una
vecchia cornacchia che ti insulta e
questi sono gli ingredienti che ci
piacciono di cucina
[Musica]
per fare un risotto al panettone così
facile da riuscire a cucinarlo questo
incompetente avrete bisogno di 80 g di
parmigiano 50 g di buco 1 scalogno 220 g
di riso 400 ml di brodo vegetale e 100
grammi di panettone Ok Eccoci qua quando
vuoi Alessandro acida Cicerone direi di
iniziare a tagliare il panettone da
quello che
a quadrettoni
Che stai facendo Stai cercando di
ottenere una promozione
quello proprio tanta fila tu lo dovresti
sapere dov'è il coltello questo non lo
vuole cominciamo
avvocato non so se
no ti fidi di me no perché no perché
dovresti farne a metà panettone con
canditi e
possiamo parlare
[Musica]
tu devi prendere una cosa e arrivare
fino in fondo altrimenti tu stai
semplicemente facendo una sacca e ho qui
taglio non fino in fondo io ho creato
semplicemente una la Gina Ok
il panettone Sei stato bravissimo tutti
Si dovrebbe se non sbaglio tagliare lo
scalogno
bravissimo Non so come si fa cioè me lo
dà almeno dimmi come secondo la mia idea
io togliere questa parte che veramente
brutta avevo io la mangerei mai cioè
partiamo dalle cose logiche
Fano mangiare Neanche questa qui perché
è veramente brutta e intanto sia la
lista poi non so come si va avanti devo
ancora cosa faresti adesso non
assomiglia a una cipolla Qui no
toglierei questa merdina Bravo la pelle
la buccia la pelle si Insomma non so
come si fa Google glielo posso spaccare
il pelo così si potresti
[Musica]
con molta attenzione fare una
piccolissima incisione e controllata
tutto ok In modo che ti viene ancora più
facile andarlo a sperare vedere un altro
afferri
lo scalogno è un mix tra 1 e una cipolla
è più una cipolla non c'è
no no
Ma come Ma come hai fatto Scusa non lo
so era così E vabbè va bene così Ma sì
ma è ovvio che si aprano hai capito
subito
Vabbè dopo questi piccoli disguidi dire
che possiamo andare avanti la trito
finemente
devo fare un soffritto per un risotto e
non lo so quando tu madre che cucinava
hai cucinato che metto a guardare come
tagliare lo scalogno Che cosa fai Ti
guardi FIFA sto sul divano aspettando
che Pronto Mamma mia
non è rubato
tutto domani per diventare così sai cosa
dico
ritmo ritmo
non è un fenomeno Però è dopo un po' che
ti prendo la mano
Va bene così Un po' invece di usarlo ti
do una dritta
[Musica]
unisci
Va bene Ora mi
continua continua hai Ok al cellulare
particolare a me le Facci volare a rigor
di logica prenderei una padella vai ok
mettiamo il burro nella pentola pentola
bravissimo mettiamo tutta Rogno quand'è
che si capisce il soffritto è pronto
quando
no per niente tutto un mappazzone un
nuovo Gene Oh no colore il colore il
colore è quale colore Montegrotto tanto
Allora noi dobbiamo ora farlo diventare
duro latino d'oratino Ok Te l'ho già che
buono dove c'è il panettone Secondo te
con un odore così ci starebbe bene se
vuoi prenotare così ci starebbe bene
qualsiasi cosa perché io trovo che il
soffritto fatto non colloquio Ma col
burro è alta è pesante a Gianmarco
assolutamente rappresentata però quanto
è buono Scusa il soffritto fatto col
burro o bisogna aggiungere ogni tanto il
brodo lì è per risultare Sei sicuro no
no no io sono sicuro che tu che hai
cucinato oggi per la prima volta nella
tua vita sappia sicuramente più non è
che l'ha letta prima di partecipare
questa capacità di trattenere le
informazioni che abbiamo
Cracco
per cuocere lo tostarlo tostarlo Cioè
questo modo Cos'è che succede perché ne
so io
in questo modo non perde quello lo so
non perde la cottura non perde la
cottura Ok
Alessandro
Aggiungete il panettone e
girate Vai il brodo Però dai Diciamo che
un po' di brodo
Com'è com'è che si cucina il riso però
gli ho detto che io non so niente non ho
studiato allora ti spiego
Qui si chiama risottatura Cioè
praticamente tu aggiungi il brodo e
senza che fai Alessandro lui ti spiego
cibo e qua dentro l'altra metà è ovunque
continua io continuo a stare
contro sta roba Adesso sta bollendo
il brodo si asciugherà se il riso non è
pronto Aggiungi un po' di altro brodo
Qua si sta asciugando se devo aggiungere
assaggiami il riso il riso cotto e crudo
correndo micro
Alessandro lo finisci prima di servire
le persone
per il
brodo
tutto dai va bene così
no no no no era rimasto un goccio
di brodo Speriamo che era rimasto un
goccio per lei tanto non è che cioè
[Musica]
il
parmigiano alla fine quando
c'è qualcosa che non va
anche se cucinasse la mano di un mano di
fuoco
[Risate]
Com'è che si chiama il processo di
mettere ora il parmigiano dentro al riso
quando ancora è caldo e girare e si va
assolutamente stavo ascoltando
non stai facendo così scusami Come si
chiama questo processo
si chiama mantecare Aggiungi parmigiano
sopra e gira gira gira gira e tu mi hai
detto gira manteca mantecato
[Musica]
cucchiaio
niente
66 presente con me siccome il brodo
uguale vita mia voce Torna alla realtà
sbaglia impiattamento
[Musica]
Allora sei pronto no
me ne vado non voglio più vicino a
questo scempio vediamo che cosa avete
fatto è una merda no no no no no no non
è vero
tanto sto d'amore di panettone
Sì Rendimi giustizia
allora
Dai fa cagare nogra lo senza ombra di
dubbio
che esagerata Mamma mia No
no A me va bene tutto però io devo dire
cosa Graziana
Gianmarco stanno facendo del loro
criticare ogni singola cosa il loro modo
per essere capito la loro carriera non è
che se lo mangi
sempre o no Graziana Perdonami L'unica
cosa che ti è piaciuta è stata la
possiamo rivedere un attimo al r.v.m. No
non è vero l'ho detto che cos'è
ragazzi Vi prego Non ci vuole niente a
farlo una piccola porzioncina ve la fate
e su Instagram mi dite se vi fa cagare o
se è buono perché secondo me è Bonino
Alessandro Grazie per aver cucinato
prima e ultima volta però è stato
bravissimo Ok allora
Vabbè posso pure deviare il cazzo Ok
ragazzi finalmente da solo Vi prego
provate taggatemi su Instagram Fatemi a
quel punto sapere se siete TIM risotto
col panettone Invece dovete seguire la
moda dei solidi sto ufficio tutto il
tifo linea allo studio a ragazzi è stato
un piacere come sempre Un bacio Alla
prossima ricetta ma tanto farà cagare
comunque